ricominciamo con l'energia
lorenzo che ringrazio prendiamo
quell'uomo che all
del della società liquida e cominciamo
da lui e vorrei che ciascuno di voi si
rivolgesse questa domanda cosa voglio
dalla vita
qual è la mia massima aspirazione
se avete la risposta o quando visto
verrà
tenete alla ii poi ci torneremo nelle
nelle filosofie orientali principalmente
il buddismo induismo tutto ciò che è
composto non ha una propria natura una
propria assenza non è reale e frutto di
una convenzione in questo periodo
d'autunno
qui no ma milano si vediamo le
formazioni degli uccelli migratori e
vediamo disegnate nel cielo delle frecce
dei cunei in realtà se noi fossimo la
cena loro vedremo piume penne uccelli
se noi ci addentriamo in una foresta
vediamo alberi tronchi arbusti cespugli
ma per quanto noi ci ha ben chiare mo
nella foresta non incontreremo mai la
foresta
questo perché è un sistema è formato
dagli elementi che lo compongono non ha
una sua essenza anche gli uomini fanno
sistema e fanno sistema principalmente
per difendersi per organizzarsi per
raggiungere i propri obiettivi un
sistema umano è composto dalle credenze
dalle opinioni dalle convinzioni anche
disomogenee delle persone che lo
innervano non è dotato di una propria
volontà
ma sono le volontà delle persone che lo
compongono che prima lo generano e poi
lo direzionano questo concetto era stato
molto ben espresso ancora a fine
ottocento da da tolstoj che in guerre
pace diceva
non è stato napoleone a portare i
francesi e mosca sono stati i francesi
che volendo arrivare a mosca hanno
generato un napoleone perché ve li
conducesse quindi se con sistema a
queste caratteristiche la famiglia un
sistema
l'azienda è un sistema l'esercito lo
stato la chiesa il mondo del lavoro sono
tutti i sistemi
certo alcuni sistemi come la famiglia
sono semplici composti di pochi elementi
altri sistemi come il mondo del lavoro
sono molto complessi composti da
sottosistemi e così via
noi facciamo parte
contemporaneamente di un gran numero di
sistemi e per ciascuno di questi siamo
chiamati con le nostre scelte con le
nostre azioni ad essere funzionali per
quel sistema
questo non è sempre possibile perché
spesso le scelte sono contraddittorie e
quindi una scelta che è funzionale per
un sistema può risultare disfunzionale
per un altro sistema
però noi apparteniamo entrambi tipico
caso è quello del lavoro e della
famiglia io sottraggo tempo ed enel al
lavoro per dedicarle alla famiglia i
miei figli
capita sempre il contrario però tant'è
funzionale per un sistema disfunzionale
per un altro altre volte le anomalie
sono finte anomalie sono animali a di
processo sembrano anomalie ma non lo
sono è il caso per esempio del plotone
di ciclisti che percorre una strada e
trova una rotatoria un ostacolo i primi
lo sa gireranno in una direzione gli
altri prende una direzione diversa per
aggirarlo nell'altra direzione ma poi si
ricongiungono e perché la meta rimane
uguale
poi ci sono delle anomalie che sono
disfunzionali per il sistema ma
generatrici di un altro il nuovo sistema
è il caso che avvenne presento nel 1823
in inghilterra quando durante una
partita del neonato football un un
giovane studente di nome web william
ellis prese il pallone con le mani e lo
portava verso la linea di fondo
il paese nel quale si giocava con la
partita era paese di rugby e di fatto
inventato il rugby quando io ero piccolo
cinque o sei anni mi lamentavo spesso
con la mia famiglia con i miei genitori
coi miei parenti perché non passavano
abbastanza tempo con me e io volevo
crescere volevo giocare volevo volevo
stare con i grandi e mi lamentavo di
questo loro si dichiaravano dispiaciuti
dicevano sì ci dispiace però sai noi
abbiamo da fare e dobbiamo lavorare
abbiamo tante cose e io sbottava dicevo
ma voi siete matti
voi siete matti voi tutti i grandi a
fare tutta la fatica che fate tutto il
lavoro che fate tutto tutte quelle cose
che fate io da grande non voglio vivere
in un mondo così io voglio vivere in un
mondo dove tu schiaccia un bottone e
succedono le cose schiaccia un bottone e
il lavoro si fa loro mi guardavano un po
straniti preoccupati poiché scrive gum
in galleria dell'aura a milano inizio
anni 60 e questo non ha voglia di
lavorare era come bestemmiare in chiesa
e dicevano guarda che non è possibile
non esiste questa cosa qui il lavoro non
si fa da solo non puoi schiacciare un
bottone e fare delle cose e io ribadivo
no non è vero quando io entro in una
camera ed è bhuyan io schiaccia un
bottone si accende la luce quando
arriviamo a casa
entriamo in ascensore schiacciano un
bottone e lui ci porta al piano
noi non dobbiamo farla
tattica di fare le scale io voglio
vivere in un mondo così dove tu
schiaccia un bottone e le cose si fanno
la fatica la fanno le macchine e loro mi
dicevano ma tu in un mondo così cosa
faresti
nel mondo così giocherei mi divertirei
coltiverà in relazioni a sei anni non
gli dicevo così però il succo era quello
sto con gli altri è esattamente quello
che faccio oggi studio mi diverto sto
con gli altri coltivo relazioni e posso
farlo non per che schiaccia un bottone
meglio perché digito e digitando
succedono cose faccio lavori ottengo
risultati allora io non lo sapevo ma il
mio dna il mio istinto mi spingeva già
nella direzione che avrebbe preso il
branco nei 50 60 anni successivi
allora ero troppo fragile insignificante
ero un anomalia troppo solitaria è
piccola per poter incidere nella realtà
che mi ero intorno ma i miei occhi erano
in osservazione le mie orecchie eroina
un ascolto il mio essere racconto a
seguire quei leader che sarebbero venuti
ne avrebbero condotto nella direzione
verso la quale io volevo andare e quei
leader sono arrivati che si chiamassero
digos che guevara o bill gates steve
jobs per i giovani d'oggi potrebbe
essere greta tombeur quei leader sono
arrivati si sono manifestati e loro sono
stati anomalia per il tempo che vivevano
ma sono quelli come me quelli come noi
come voi che li abbiamo fatti diventare
sistema quei leader sono stati il
napoleone
noi siamo stati i francesi che gli
abbiamo immaginato
altrimenti non ci sarebbe stato il
progresso e il mondo è cambiato e io
penso che il mondo sia cambiato in
meglio
ma allora se io faccio parte di più
sistemi contemporaneamente come faccio a
sapere se in un sistema devo sforzarmi
migliorarmi dare il meglio di me per
contribuire alla funzionalità di quel
sistema oppure se non sia preferibile
sparigliare e prendere il pallone con le
mani
all'inizio di questo intervento che ho
fatto una domanda cosa voglio dalla vita
qual è la mia massima aspirazione
io non so quali siano le vostre risposte
se diventare l'uomo più ricco del mondo
proprietario di un isola avere una vita
sana morire a cent'anni una famiglia
numerosa o che altro
so però che tutte le vostre risposte
qualunque sia lo hanno un unico comune
denominatore è quell unico con numero e
denominatore si chiama felicità
io voglio essere felice noi vogliamo
essere felici perché tutti gli uomini
vogliono essere felici ma guardate che
quando parlo di felicità
non intendo il momento di gioia una
generica contentezza
non intendo è il pensiero positivo
piuttosto che
il tramutare il problema in
un'opportunità o cose del genere
la felicità per come la intendo io è
qualcosa di più profondo qualcosa che ha
a che fare con l'autorealizzazione
merlino diceva con il potenziale umano
ecco la felicità è quella cosa lì la
felicità in questa accezione non è un
obiettivo è un bisogno della persona è
un bisogno dell'essere è una
responsabilità personale riuscirò a
esser felice nella misura in cui mi
adopererò per essere felice di essere
autentico quella è la felicità e come
faccio a ottenere quel tipo di felicità
e io penso che ciascuno di noi
attraverso l'introspezione attraverso la
consapevolezza debba ricercare quel
bambino che è stato quello che voleva
schiacciare i bottoni e mettersi in
contatto con lui e l'adulto che siamo
oggi dovrebbe prendere quel bambino per
mano sorreggerlo proteggerlo aiutarlo ma
lasciare che sia lui a prendere le
decisioni che contano
perché quel bambino li sa che il dono
della vita e il dono della felicità che
il potenziale umano rene per essere
espresso che lui sa dov'è l'eccellenza
losacco il bambino allora lui ci
indicherà qual è la strada e da certi
sistemi ci farà uscire fuori e noi
saremo felici per il fatto stesso di
esserne usciti e renderci conto che
abbiamo recuperato tempo ed energie in
altri sistemi invece ci spingerà ad
adoperarci a migliorarci ad allenarci a
giocare il pallone coi piedi perché
quella fatica che faremo
servirà ad essere funzionali a un
sistema che ci porterà nella direzione
dove
dovremo andare e infine altre volte quel
bambino ci spingerà a raccogliere quel
pallone da terra che tutti prendono a
calci a stringerlo al cuore ea correre
con quello verso la linea di fondo
allora in quel momento a noi non
interesserà sapere se siamo anomalia o
siamo sistema perché in quel momento con
quel pallone al cuore noi saremo felici
e nella vita non ci servirà altro
grazie
[Applauso]